today we're talking about god of war
ragnarok and for spoken getting new
release dates as well as looter shooters
preparing to take over your phone
battery
it's official god of war ragnarok has a
release date this continuation of the
best father-son story in gaming will hit
shelves on november 9th for playstation
5 and playstation 4. four additions will
be available at launch and pre-orders
will start on july 15th at 7 a.m pacific
time 10 a.m eastern if you pre-order any
edition of ragnarok you'll receive two
in-game cosmetics kratos risen snow
armor and atreus risen snow tunic if
you're the type of gamer that loves
replicas the 16 inch mjolnir hammer that
comes with the collectors and yachtner
editions is perfect for you personally i
love figures but that hammer definitely
caught my attention this morning
playstation has an unboxing video for
both editions of the game so check out
that video later if you're interested
but god of war isn't the only game that
got a shiny new release date today for
spoken the action rpg from square enix
has been pushed from october to january
24th 2023. in a statement the company
said all game elements are complete and
the remaining development time will be
used for final polishing this of course
is a bummer because i'm really excited
for forspoken despite those less than
stellar previews but it's completely
fine because as i always say delay delay
delay to keep the cyberpunk disease at
bay and yes i know cyberpunk got delayed
as well you don't need to spam it in the
comments instead let's talk about how
you should be downloading and playing
the matrix awakens unreal 5 demo before
it's delisted from the playstation and
xbox storefront on saturday july 9. epic
games announced this news on the demo's
official site writing quote not explored
the matrix awakens and unreal 5
experience yet there's still time the
unreal 5 tech demo will only be
available in stores until july 9.
download it before that date and you'll
still be able to access the demo going
forward or re-download it if you've
deleted it from your console why epic
games has decided to remove the tech
demo from the digital storefronts is
unclear but as with many issues in the
gaming world it could potentially be a
licensing reason and in some unrelated
news bungie the developer behind destiny
and chinese tech company netease are
reportedly working on a new first person
shooter for mobile as reported by the
gaming post a linkedin profile of one of
the netease games artists indicates that
the company is helping bungie create an
unannounced fps mobile game neither
bungie nor netease have announced any
plans for a new mobile game but a source
with knowledge of the development plans
told the publication that the team is
currently working on a new destiny game
the source also suggested that the
unannounced destiny mobile game is not
related to bungie's destiny 2 in any way
but has been in the works for well over
2 years and even though that game's
existence seems up in the air the
division mobile game is very real and
now has a trailer titled the division
resurgence this game is based in the
universe of the division and will be a
co-op third-person shooter rpg with a
separate story that will be canonical to
the larger universe ubisoft is referring
to the game as an open world and says
players will be able to roam freely
around the urban environment and will
feature both story missions and world
activities for cooperative agents to
complete and if you're like me don't
worry because ubisoft also says the game
can be played alone but like any other
online game it's probably more fun with
friends like say fall guys which went
free to play recently and announced they
hit 50 million players in two weeks
it's fun to run those courses alone but
it's also fun to just compete with
friends and have a squad next to you so
if you haven't played yet
i'd suggest jumping in and maybe drop
your epic name down below and maybe we
can play together i need to be a little
more social you know
i'll see you in the next one